what's going on are we live
is this thing on
[Music]
[Music]
10
times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly in sinks and
showers elements and bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
orleans pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
your lucky stars every day you're not
dave beckman
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks
[Music]
look at that look at that
man's a loser pac-man's a loser
pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser
like that
look at
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers jones has
fake callers this is just
this is just a
this is just a
this is just a
corporate takeover censorship debanking
harass tyranny
all right welcome everybody we're
standing by for president joe biden the
question is uh is there gonna be a war
between russia and ukraine we don't know
the answer maybe joe biden will tell us
but a lot a lot a lot is writing on this
national address that we are standing by
for uh just uh just moments away um the
stock market
another
very shaky day very very shaky day and
closing in about 11 minutes
um and it's conceivable that we will
hear something from joe biden that will
be positive from the standpoint of
not going to war
now there are many
who believe i am a
an
imperialist bastard
you bastard
pacman's a loser globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike obama trudeau macron right and
the rest of these zio beasts right
right
but um i'm not and uh there are
political reasons for which i don't want
russia and ukraine to be at war and the
u.s to be involved but at the end of the
day guys
just to keep my stocks up i don't want
there to be war like even if you were to
believe the false claims that i'm some
kind of imperialist
um
i don't want stocks dropping even more
it's been a very very rough month
um oh and by the way
this is a weird thing um
there was this post i spotted on the on
the subreddit when david says things
like people call me an imperialist he
should show or play it
um he says i don't doubt he's getting
voicemails it's just really showing
oh wait a second now with oh it looks
like they've edited their post anyway
this post initially oh here it is it's
hard for him to criticize the right when
they do it to set a bunch of fake fires
to put out when he doesn't do it anyway
the point was this person seemed to be
saying like if i should prove that
people are saying that to me and and i
literally went and looked at one of my
ukraine videos and immediately found
these three comments you're just
repeating establishment talking points
and neocon lies david i'm not an
imperialist but let's have war find me
one clip where i say let's have war find
me one clip where i imply let's have war
find me one clip where i say or intimate
in any way
that i want the united states involved
one
just one find one example
here's another one you are an
imperialist
john paul says tulsi is a twisted
grifter but you're brazenly lying
warmongering imperialist trash david
find me one segment guys find me one
and i find that there's a lot of this uh
gutter trash
posted to a lot of other host subreddits
it's a very
kind of toxic aspect of the um
terminally online left
which is to go to other people's people
used to call sam sader and complain
about my imperialist takes with no
examples and then now
they go to other subreddits they go to
the you know they go to the stephen
kenneth destiny bennell the second
subreddit oh they go to the ian vausch
subreddit or they go to kyle kulinski's
subreddit and they go pacman's
imperialist takes he's desperate for war
find me one clip guys find me one clips
jesus
um okay uh so that's that and we're
standing by for joe biden i i should i
mention i don't want a war between
russia and ukraine do you guys think
it's it's relevant should i i don't know
if i've made that clear
i've not made it clear okay well i
apologize
i don't want war i hope joe biden's
going to tell us we're not going to war
dear god
thank you to polo dal
and twitching mangoes or i guess i
should say twitching mangoes for the
twitch prime subscriptions numbers one
and two i wanna invite you
immediately to sign up at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code obama
and you can get a a huge discount okay
so we took care of that very quick
programming note right at the conclusion
of this stream i'll be doing an
instagram ama okay um if you look at my
story ask me anything
ask me anything so
we've already gotten a few dozen
questions i'll start answering these in
video and textual format at the
immediate conclusion of today's stream
that's on our this is on the show
instagram see it's david pakman show not
mine
okay it's the show instagram very very
important stuff and i look forward to
you
um
asking me some questions we're gonna
have some questions there
what else do i have oh rumble as many of
you know we are now on rumble
the comments are um
dangerously weaponized
let's just see here here's one clip what
is what are people saying
oh i have to sign in oh dear god hold on
a second
let me do that
i don't even know my password i mean
this is crazy
man
and i'm logged out okay i'm blocked okay
sorry guys well that's forget it
i'm now blocked from rumble too bad
um
so i was going to show you guys all the
crazy comments but i guess i can't do it
you can find us at davidpakman.com
ruffle it'll block you pretty quick
thanks to jen here for gifting a twitch
subscription also a huge thank you to
joyce rudberg
joyce rudberg signing up on my website
joinpackman.com
and his new member number
of four as you can see there i hope all
who are any of you going to be joining
me for the joe biden state of the union
on march 1st we're going to be live
an hour before
and then after we'll be potentially
taking your comments and no i'm not i'm
i'm locked out guys not blocked i'm
locked out good a lot of you guys are
going to be there that's great
that's great it's going to be a very
very strong stream thanks to ireman for
the twitch prime subscription love it
um
tim poole recently talked about me and i
don't even know what he's talking about
do you guys want to take a look at it
let's see here it is lip says will you
ever uh will you ever have david pakman
on do you agree with anything he says uh
david is always welcome to come on yes
and i think david is wrong because i
don't think david does i'm wrong about
what does journalism i don't claim to do
journalism i do commentary and i don't
mean that as a
as i don't mean that disrespectfully
it's it's not a question of respect but
i don't know what i'm wrong about who
said i do journalism when dave rubin
told uh i think he tweeted aoc i like
how he says dave rubins like paul rubins
like hey someone on your team thinks i'm
a journalist please stop saying this to
me she no he was like please stop
sending me your press releases and then
she responded with oh someone must have
thought you were a journalist we'll get
you removed promptly all these leftists
were like do you guys know what this is
he confusing dave rubin and dave pakman
i don't know what the reuben story has
to do with me
he's like pacman is wrong because reuben
asked something about aoc dick burn and
it's like dave rubin was never a
journalist he's a comedian do you guys
understand how we got from me to dave
rubin does anybody know okay i mean i'm
honestly saying does anybody know how we
got to
reuben from me
nobody knows okay
let's see he's a comedian political
commentator yeah so he was like i'm not
a journalist don't send me these and
they're acting like it was a burn it
just makes no sense so anyway what i
mean is yeah there have been uh um
i've i haven't watched as much of
david's stuff as uh in a while as i used
to but you know i mentioned often how
when ted cruz correctly cited politico
and the new york times pertaining to
ukraine meddling in the 2016 election to
help democrats
instead of actually google searching the
stories to see if it was true david just
mocked trump
what is he talking about
what is he talking about
when
ted
i mean i guess it's conceivable
i did what he's talking about i don't
remember it it's also confusing because
he's sort of talking about two different
people named david and he see i think
now he's back to me right like i think
now he's talking about me
not reuben is that true
because he was asked about me
and i'm just like it's a weird thing
because it takes you five seconds to do
this to look up the new york times
article that says ukrainian court rules
that you know individuals meddled in the
election to help democrats you can just
look that up
it takes you five seconds it's the new
york times but david didn't even do that
what is it i don't even know what he's
talking about i didn't do that when
so my opinion on david is he's entitled
to his opinions on certain things we
have we have different politics but i
thought he was on the left what does it
mean we have different he he
wasn't his whole thing that he's on the
left how do we have different politics i
mean i know now he voted for trump but i
think over the past several years he's
just uh his show is based on
you know look he provides commentary on
the commentary of others
no i provide commentary he almost got it
it's funny he goes i was wrong because
i'm not a journalist like okay i didn't
tell anybody i'm a journalist
and now he says i provide commentary on
other commentaries no i provide
commentary
that's it it's not
i mean you know
it's not that difficult to figure out
what i'm doing like in that circumstance
he was watching meet the press and then
commenting on the opinions of meet the
press instead of doing research and my
god guys anyway um the the reason that i
have not talked to tim poole in a while
i've said it before is
we as with many people
i have private conversations and i had a
private conversation with him about
social media marketing and then he just
like publicly disclosed the details of
that conversation and it's not so much
that
the content was like
concerning or whatever it's just like i
thought we were having a private
conversation like when you know when i
have a conversation with sam cedar about
like
how are you you know marketing your show
or whatever
implicitly i'm not gonna then go and say
hey you guys know what's going on with
like
it's a private conversation and when i
told him i said tim
um
that was a private conversation
he just doubled down and said i don't
believe in that i don't believe in uh
you know and what's funny is in order to
tell you guys this i sort of have to
describe our private conversation like i
understand that but i you know i think
you you understand why i'm doing it he
was like i don't i don't accept the
concept of that private i'm not this is
like hillary clinton with her private
and public positions i'm like tim i'm
not talking about private and public
positions what i'm saying is
we had a a personal conversation
and then you went and later tweeted
about it and tried to weaponize it
against me and he never apologized if he
just apologized or he was like oh my my
bad my bad
we would be fine and i'm sure i would
have appeared on his show i would have
had him back on mine it's like it's
really not a big deal it's just kind of
common decency you know uh what's
another example um
i don't know i was recently emailing
with jenk yuger
i wouldn't tweet about the things jenk
and i talk about or like when kyle
kolinsky texts me i'm not gonna then go
to the air and report that to you guys
it's just common decency you know it's
maybe maybe i'm old-fashioned maybe i'm
old-fashioned i don't know so anyway
good i'm welcome on his show i mean the
reason i haven't been on his show is we
haven't spoken
since this incident happened that's it
it's it's it's just that simple
okay thanks to d4
rel
for the twitch prime subscription number
six today i would love it if you're
watching right now and if you're not how
would you even know
is anybody here right now who isn't
watching
is that even possible
okay for the people that are here and
are watching okay
i should i should have realized for the
people who are here and are watching
it's a great day to re-up your twitch
prime subscription it's a great day to
get a website membership we got by the
way i am going to be delivering this the
day before biden's state of the union i
will be delivering our state of the show
and i hope to be able to mention you
and uh a great way to do that is to grab
a membership on my website and of course
you can use the coupon code obama obama
one of the great uh uh benefits of being
a member is the bonus show which alex
jones hates oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
right right okay um let's see i've got a
couple other things here as we stand by
at a clark county school board meeting
an anti-mask parent claimed asians are
better at math
okay let's see
covet has a 99.7
survival rate
um i'd also like to address teachers in
school who still think
this prevents a virus like oh my gosh
i'm scared for
society and also the reason asians are
doing better in math isn't because
they're genetically superior it's
because they have
uh a higher rate of two parents in the
household oh okay all right well that's
uh so it's more of a social thing than a
genetic thing let's focus on that i
never heard one person discuss about two
parent households on how to improve
certain demographics and please get your
kids out of ccsd it's garbage these
people are anti-oxygen they are
pro-pedophile and they're out for your
kids
you know one of the interesting things
about mask is
yes
you might be saying they want to block
oxygen with the mask
what they really might want to block is
nitrogen because there's a lot more
nitrogen
do i have not heard a single parent
confront a school board and tell them do
you realize the air we breathe is
riddled with nitrogen and none of these
masked people will say a word about it
that's the real cover-up
it is just nitrogen everywhere and
people are going about their day like
this is normal
it's and don't even get me started on
argonne
okay so that's this woman's opinion
um here's a really weird
dad
whose daughter just turned 21
and uh he's
like talking about
her virginity it's it's very very
strange this is i guess like
you know i'm not really part of
conservative culture so there might be
something about this video that i just
don't understand but let's take a look
hannah turned 21 last sunday and no she
didn't go to bars and party like the
world and drank it up i did not drink
she is still a virgin at 21 years old
see with god all things are possible
it's still possible in the evil
generation that we live in that you
could be 21 you could still be pure you
can still be holy you can still keep
yourself clean and unspotted so here's a
21 year old girl did he say unspotted
but i've never even heard that
totally
virgin i'm not i'm and i say virgin i'm
talk i know i'm sounding getting a
little detailed i'm talking boys haven't
touched her yet okay
because sometimes i think you ladies out
there if a guy touches you you think
that's clean that's not clean
can you ima how does a person like this
like how does this girl
even have a shot
out there in the real world right like
how did she
when this when this is your dad how do
you even have a shot at success but
don't ever let a guy touch you and think
that's clean okay it's still sexual
immorality so keep yourself clean and
spotted with god uh kirsten my other 15
year old she she doesn't take her phone
i don't give her internet inside of her
bedroom um you got to be very careful
but you got her in a faraday cage how do
you block the internet just in the
bedroom for what you watch uh we do not
i guess she's not allowed to bring the
phone in i see
um cussing movies uh filthy language if
they say damn the 15 year old is not
allowed to see it this girl is now 21 so
she will be allowed to watch movies
where they say
uh
anyway movies or sex scenes if you watch
a movie that has a sex scene you're
watching pornography they're not even
allowed to watch the scene in the
never-ending story where the horse dies
in the quicksand that's it's too much
for the 21 year old in a few in 10 more
years she'll be allowed to watch that
hollywood for the most part is demonic
and if you
um start watching movies and tv shows
that have sex scenes in it i mean you're
just elite you're unleashing demonic
spirits more or less yeah into your
house it's a floodgate coming in
porn is um
it creates uh brain damage they say let
alone spiritual damage right pornography
is demonic i know some of you are
watching are probably addicted to porn
or watching or struggling with porn when
you watch it i guarantee
you demons are being released into your
mind and your heart and it's just
killing you and destroying you no one
does
big time drugs
without going to marijuana first and
it's the some people do actually that's
very much untrue same thing with
pornography it's feeding you just a
little bit at a time porn leads into
child porn it leads into human sex
trafficking yes
that's actually how matt gates ended up
doing human sex trafficking
he just he once watched like an nc-17
movie next thing you know he was
trafficking girls why we're seeing a
monster monster we have a major problem
with human sex trafficking today because
pornography is off the charts if anyone
is on here is it has this video been
going on so long it seems to be getting
darker like it seems like the sun is
setting it has suicidal thoughts i pray
for them they will there will be greater
damnation if they commit it it's a very
selfish act
she has no boyfriend right no we got
that we got we understand we understand
um really really scary stuff
i mean it almost seems like that's child
abuse i don't know
it's very very crazy let me look at some
super chats ceo at crystalsoft says what
are your thoughts on the us wanting war
and stoking the media into fanning the
flames seems like the u.s and russia
both want a small conflict to distract
from internal problems i have not found
evidence that that is the case so i
would not be able to
i i i don't
have a reason right now to believe
that's the case
meg says david what do you want to see
in a political candidate that neither
side is delivering actual authenticity
photo says somebody check his browser
history i know the guy is creeping me
out i'm not going to lie that guy was
very creepy
i want to say thank you to mercutio head
who just made a twitch prime
subscription also huge thank you to dean
reiger dean just did something
incredible dean went to join pacman.com
and signed up with the coupon code obama
obama if you're just joining us we are
standing by to hear from president joe
biden
is there going to be a war between
russia and ukraine and if the answer is
yes is the u.s getting involved i hope
the answer to both questions is no
but we're about to hear from president
joe biden and hopefully he will tell us
if you are just joining us we also are
in the middle of an ama on the david
pakman show instagram
um you can ask me whatever you want on
there and right after this stream is
done oh hold on i closed it out let me
go back in there right after this stream
is done
i will um
here it is
oh whoops this is something else no this
one right here
uh right after the stream is done i will
start answering questions so that's
david pakman show on instagram ama
happening right now and i will get to
questions as soon as we are
done with the stream
we have a hype train starting over on
twitch i want to say thanks to deb z and
tempst
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 9 and 10.
um and i i would invite you to sign up
on our website yeah we actually um
we we're we're loading up a bunch of
additional great member benefits as many
of you know when we do these david
pakman show live town halls our website
members get priority handling and it's
it is wild what happens during these
town halls so i invite you to sign up
there
um
joshua asks did i miss the biden speech
you did not
you did not we are standing by for joe
biden momentarily and in theory in
theory
he is going to
uh
tell us
whether
there will or will not be war
between russia and ukraine and i hope
the answer is no
thanks to jen here for gifting another
twitch subscription i really appreciate
that also thanks to toil for gifting
five
pushing us all the way to sixteen
i do have a wacky
dave ramsey clip
man i don't know if i want to do the
dave ramsey clip now you know i think i
might i think i'm gonna because i expect
joe biden is gonna speak soon
i'm just gonna save the ramsay clip for
now and maybe we'll do it after if not
we'll hold it for the next stream
because i really need time to devote to
it there's a lot of uh
weaponized disinformation in the dave
ramsey
clip
um oh and also thanks to brianna or
brianna stanfield who just signed up on
my website with the code obama obama
that is number 17 today let's do a
couple voicemails yeah i have a crazy
amount of voicemails um let's go uh
let's get really crazy let's go to the
wacky triumvirate which is whitney eric
from mass and billy harrison with some
troy york thrown in let's listen
so what i'm noticing about the news and
also like the politicians is they've
like gridlocked each other to like make
more money
like if
there is a black lives matter protest
right here's eric from mass
hey david eric from mass i know you
don't like facts or
truth or anything like that but project
veritas have the fda guy
and it's straight from the fda guy's
mouth that uh it's all about money in
there all right so there there he is now
we go to troy york hey david pakman why
are you not covering
the democrat party civil war
the undemocrat socialists are
there's almost no socialists in the
democratic party i mean the reason i'm
not covering that civil war is because
it's not real
so what i noticed about um the latvians
is that um their thing is like
the orange here
i've never met a latvian with orange
hair i have to admit i just i just
haven't and i would admit it if i had
here's back to eric from mass
hey david it's eric from mass can you
comment on the new video release from
the capital one six where um they open
the doors from the inside and the guy
keeps going back and forth no i haven't
seen that one back to troy york
david pakman i'm watching the stephen
crowley show don't care don't care what
stephen crowder's doing back to eric
from mass
hey dave and it's eric from math go to
cdc.gov
yes very good website i'm familiar with
it back to whitney
hi um so i was looking at the
myers-briggs um characters again okay
i'm done with myers-briggs for now back
to eric from mass
hey david it's sarah from math i just
wanted to call him say i feel bad but um
i just talked to my doctor and
he told me about the vaccine it uh
wipes away the t8 cells which eat cancer
cells nope doesn't do that back to
whitney
so i noticed that enneagram 1 was typed
as jesus
and then um
what causes like the enneagram one
stress is four
and four is typed as like the creative
one
so
i would think like in order to kind of
like dominate in
judaism
whoa dominating judaism is pretty
serious okay so that's every single day
for years on our voicemail every single
day just getting smashed over the head
again and again and again and again
um okay
other super chats no no other super
chats thank you to janat mar
as well as tr napsta
plus swolobe has gifted five that's a
total of seven putting us at 24. very
much appreciate that guys we're actually
on a level five hype train we've not
succeeded on a level five hype train for
a very very long time i also want to say
thank you to jay gelnat
and eric hodges both jay and eric
just got memberships on my website they
also use the coupon code obama obama
which uh the the discount is huge um
we call it massive but i think i should
probably change that to huge hold on
let's change that
there we go oh and i miss my parentheses
just say bigly huge
yeah that makes sense that makes more
sense okay chaka seki says david i'm
worried mike lindell's operation pillow
drop could end in tragedy and a cloud of
canadian goose feathers on the convoy
you know chakaseki
chakaseki is the resident show
um
a radiologist as you guys know these
witty with these witticisms are sent by
dr chakaseki
between
reading cat scans and other imaging
elements and people think i'm joking
when i say that he's literally a
radiologist and i imagine him down in a
dark room reading and going yes it's a
stress fracture and then going hey what
about mike pillow
someone told me that the mic pillows
come in a cube
and so it would actually be you know we
imagine just dropping dropping feathers
like that's no big deal but apparently
they come in a cube and it could really
hurt people if he were to do an air drop
of the pillows but i don't know if
that's true
joshua says obama
obama love you david you've kept me sane
and alive during the pandemic appreciate
that
laura says i feel like i should call a
voicemail that just says hey how are you
have a great day those are very rare
laura very very rare
levy or levi says do you think this will
result in an all-out war between the u.s
and russia no i am optimistic that it
will not
uh extremely strong things happening
over on twitch i want to say thank you
to cosmos cooper the copper dragon
mitch patley erroneous
sterling lana and tri killer eric
seven additional twitch prime
subscriptions very very much appreciate
that
really appreciate it
iran says can you look at wyoming bill
sf5 anti-trans bill on student sports
and schools i'll check it out
i will check it out
c wilson says david sir have you
listened to the podcast uneffing the
republic what do you think not only do i
think it's great um they've uh they've
sponsored our show before which might
make my opinion
irrelevant because they were a sponsor
but no it's a great podcast
knight says i don't think the u.s can
take another biden trump election cycle
that's uh
not untrue theoretically not untrue
theoretically someone is urgently trying
to get a hold of me
and i don't know who it is hold on what
is this number
what is this oh
let's see here
gotta send a text i apologize
okay just a little bit of a not done but
just a minor minor minor emergency
and then i'm also getting sent things
okay i was sent something that we would
want to look at oh this is interesting
let me email it to myself
copy link
oh it's a mark levin clip let's see what
it is
it's on tick tocks let's take a look at
this
i have not pre-screened this just so
people know
about what's going on in this country
i'll tell you what's going on in this
country the largest political party in
this country hates america
they hate our security they hate our
constitution they hate our founders they
hate our framers he's talking about
republicans right
they hate our history
they hate our family structure
uh and there's so much that they hate
about america that we have a vice
president who's probably among the
dumbest vice presidents in american
history there have been many stupid ones
it's funny because like i
kamala harris hasn't done too much but
she doesn't seem stupid to me i wonder
if there's some other reason mark levin
feels that way who makes comments about
this country
that are just so vile and so repugnant
and i would say this to kamala harris
you need to go over to these military
cemeteries and take a look
and take a look at all those crosses and
those stars of david and think about all
the men and all the women who died for
this country that you trash
that made who you are and what you are
possible because god knows you haven't
invested into this country what those
people did and now this guy this is just
reactionary trash it's it's not
i'm going to text back the person who
sent it to me
um
yeah it's it's just rea it we should we
should pay no attention to it whatsoever
it's just garbage it's just complete and
total garbage
uh okay so we've taken care of that i
want to say thank you to matthew
brackley matthew just signed up on my
website with the coupon code obama obama
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] uh that's
about mark levin by the way not uh yes
not not our new member um number 34
today which i very very much appreciate
other super chats coming in judy says i
might be done donating to democrats
because we can't even seem to get our
members to vote together well assuming
you're talking about mansion and cinema
the solution is we got to flip some more
seats we don't want to be depending on
mansion and cinema quite frankly
uh
you know if
it weren't mansion and cinema we might
end up with just straight-up republicans
in those seats i don't know that that's
really the solution we're looking for so
i would just tread carefully to some
degree
uh okay
let's uh you know what let's do the
ramsey clip because it seems biden's
running very late this producer pat sent
this to me i've told many of you guys
dave ramsey is a right-wing nut
ideologue do not listen to him for
financial advice his financial advice
that is good is so basic you can get it
anywhere
and the stuff that's bad is really bad
take a look at this
[Music]
kelly is in traverse city michigan hi
kelly welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and rachel pleasure talking to
you both you too how can we help
my husband and i are disagreeing on what
to do with his student loans
we currently owe 17 000
we have the cash right now to pay them
off
but we're both registered nurses here in
northern michigan and the ceo of our
hospital
is implementing a retention plan which
is
forgiveness for twelve thousand dollars
of federal student loans
but because if the retention plan it is
two hundred dollars a month for the next
you know four to five years
and
i would like to just pay them off and be
done with it not have the debt hanging
over ahead but my husband
thinks that taking an advantage of this
free money is the smarter
it's not supportive
your husband is wrong
so what do you do in your marriage when
your husband's wrong
well
kelly i'm sorry i feel for you i do
okay so the question here is
they have 17k in loans
they have the cash to pay it
the business they work for is offering
200 a month or 2400 a year
no indication that you have to stay in
the job
uh
whatever okay so dave just says don't
accept the free money just pay it off
all right okay well let's listen and
this is hard because here's
oh let's come back let's come back to
this this is a good conversation okay
all right all right hold on hold on
kelly we'll come back rachel rachel
wants to be reasonable hold on we'll
come right back we're talking with kelly
in traverse city michigan uh her
hospital is offering a twelve thousand
dollar forgiveness over five years
um and uh they owe seventeen thousand
student loans they have the money to pay
it off she wants to pay it off her
husband doesn't what do i do was her
question and i was joking with her and
saying what do you do when your
husband's wrong but um so anyway that's
how far we got is that a fair summary of
what you told us kelly
yeah okay
okay so what i was going to say kelly is
and again this is a little stereotypical
so it's not true 100 of the time but
generally men
tend to lean more on
kind of that the the logic
math side a little less on the emotional
side right women so first of all this is
dave ramsey's daughter and so right away
she goes into
gender stereotypes about how people deal
with money this is the dumbest it is
shocking to me that
millions of people dave ramsey probably
is worth 200 million dollars off of this
stuff and people go to him and they
think it's free it's brilliant
so
okay let's do a little more okay i feel
like can naturally go there a little bit
quicker than men
so when it comes to debt and and even
student loans there's this
this idea that yeah if i can just do the
math it's going to play out right so
he's looking at the math he's seeing the
logic and he's thinking yeah i mean
someone's going to pay this off this is
great
where you're feeling on the other end we
have the money and there's a level of of
probably less stress a level of freedom
that you know you're going to experience
when this is paid off am i am i right or
wrong is this correct right yeah yes if
you guys think you even know where this
is going you have no idea just wait
so whenever couples do tend to disagree
especially when it comes to money um i
think
going to him because you hesitated when
he said what are you doing your
husband's wrong uh so i don't know how
you guys do conflict i don't know how
you come to decision making uh we've
only been talking for about 30 seconds
but
one thing i really would encourage you
to do okay the person saying this
eventually gets to be about vaccination
is a hundred percent correct is to go to
him and and we always say tell him your
why
and and and that why
may not make logical sense because to
him he's thinking i'm gonna get free
money
and someone's gonna pay this off and you
know x y and z
and to really unpack with him
you what you're seeing what you're
feeling
and why you want this paid off and that
could be because you don't want
your
destiny in someone else's hands we talk
about that a lot when it comes to
student loans a lot of people depend on
whether it's
dc or these programs that say hey if you
work for us 10 years we'll pay it off
who knows what's going to happen right
in all this time
and when you're passive and you let
other people
handle your future now of course you're
not doing any of that it's a question of
do i accept 200 a month in free money
for the time that i'm in this job that's
all it is you're letting go of really
the will to go and say i can change my
life no you're not you just now have a
free 200 bucks you would consider when
you think about changing jobs that's all
so there could be an ownership issue
that you struggle with for you maybe you
are just stressed with just having debt
whether it was a car loan or student
loan doesn't matter you don't like
having the debt i don't know what it is
for you kelly but whatever that why is
of i
i want this paid off because we have the
money
go to him with that first and foremost
versus blaming or
being accusatory uh really when you go
with that notice they still haven't
actually done the financial analysis
there are emotional components here
which i will get to but the first thing
is do the financial this he's supposedly
a financial advisor why i think it's one
of the best ways to start and open up
the conversation
so that is really good counsel let me
give you the let me tell you why he's
wrong and maybe that'll help too
okay okay if you told me they were going
to pay you 12 000 as a retention bonus
in 12 months
i'd go with him on it
but you're not you're getting two
hundred dollars a month it's not
speeding
it's not spit that's 2400 a year
right okay it's it's like 15 of the
total loan a year it's actually not
nothing this is dragging out forever
forever and this is this is golden
handcuffs and a highly volatile
coveted laced vaccination world
that you live in the middle of
oh wait what
what where health care workers are
on the front line
and you don't want to be handcuffed to
anything you want to keep your freedom
because you may have to make some
different choices there's even people on
the left who follow this guy
and this is golden handcuffs
yeah right now the the interest is zero
percent so interest isn't relevant that
side is it right but one once again it
actually is the fact that's not two
hundred dollars isn't even covering the
interest
that's a good point too but it is
relevant
well if it's zero now then accruing
interest isn't a concern right now so
why wouldn't you so listen guys it it's
all about vac i don't even want to play
the rest of it it ends up being all
about vaccination okay
i don't i mean okay like i get i i'm not
going to say i have no knowledge in this
i have an mba in financial planning so i
have a take on this the way i would
approach a question like this if i want
to be seen as a so-called expert right
is to say hey you know what this is a
really good question
when it comes to debt there's an
emotional component what do you think
about figuring out the the financial
piece first and then we think about the
emotional piece oh that makes sense dave
ramsey pacman whoever okay that's how
you would start
and then i would say okay
is there do you are you committing to
stay at this job if you accept the free
money no it's very clear that it's not a
requirement you can just start getting
the 200 bucks a month great
are you accruing interest
if you start accepting this money and
you don't pay it off no she said right
now there's no interest oh okay
how long do you plan to stay at this job
i don't know
you're gonna stay at least a year yeah
probably you're gonna stay five maybe
not okay fine
so
what you could say is you're gonna get
200 a month
uh would that 200 be taxable i don't
know that's a question for an account i
i i'm saying me david pakman i don't
know whether the 200 is taxable
um
it depends whether it's direct payments
is it a fringe benefit is it in i have
no idea but you would figure out is
there some tax on it or or not fine
um and then you would say well you're
not accruing any interest so take your
17k
put it in something that's safe you can
get point six percent on a high yield
savings you could find a cd
for 1.1 you know fig figure it out and
then because you have the cash if you
only last a year
you've gotten 2 400 bucks from them 200
a month and then you made a little bit
of money on your 17
and when you quit the job you pay off
the rest
or if you last two years now they've
paid 4 800 bucks and you've had your 17
000 working for you for two years you
quit the job now you only owe 12 8 or 11
8 and you've kept right so hey you know
what caller that's the financial answer
now let's talk about something
completely different
um
is it weighing on you to have the
seventeen thousand in debt does it is
there a psychological thing and whenever
people say should i pay off my mortgage
it's a financial consideration well i
can deduct the interest on the mortgage
but only up to a certain limit and
there's the salt cap and this that
what's the interest rate you figure that
out but then it's like at the end of the
day does it does it bother you to have a
mortgage when you might when you could
opt out of the mortgage and it ends up
being a combination of a financial
decision and an emotional decision
i don't even
you know i don't even pretend to have
the answer here uh and and so there's
like good there's good comments here
david
emotions are valid sometimes doing the
optimal thing isn't worth the stress but
the way to deal with that is you place a
value on that exactly right
exactly right
anyway this guy is the worst and it's
really depressing to me that so many
people i know that the people on the
right love it this guy dave ramsey got a
call the other day
from someone who who was like dave
because one of dave ramsey's things is
you gotta tithe ten percent to your
church
um and someone called and was like dave
i don't think uh
i don't think i can afford to keep doing
10
i just can't it's so everything's so
tight in my finances and dave was like i
bet things aren't that tight let's just
find areas for you to spend less so that
you can keep tithing to the church like
well you know
maybe the you don't know the budget dude
uh okay people saying who should you
listen to honestly i i hate to tell you
this because the entire world of
financial advice
and financial advising is based on the
on the principle that this stuff is
really really difficult
you actually don't really need to watch
anything you there's probably 10 books
that i would recommend that you get
um and i should i should actually make a
list of them
um but these are like really
really basic books that teach you the
most fundamental principles there's also
good bloggers
it's it's like a handful of principles
i'll put a list together one that i'm
reading now he he's he's a buddy he's
going to be on the show soon
is uh he just wrote it
actually this book isn't out yet okay
nick majuli who's a financial blogger
young guy he has a new book called just
keep buying
and uh i would recommend that when it's
out morgan housel's the psychology of
money is a good one
um
[Music]
there's just you know there's 10 or 12
books
that really give you all the principles
and then you can figure it all out with
on the basis of those principles
um this
i i know that it's like sometimes people
get mad when people go you know it's
actually really simple it really
actually is doesn't mean you have the
money to do the things that you should
be doing in the order you're supposed to
be doing them but it's actually the
principles are really simple eventually
you get into more complicated things
like
let me give you a more complicate like a
real complicated question where you
would be like let me find a fee only
financial advisor fee only remember you
don't want someone
taking one two percent to manage your
money
let's say you had a situation
where you'd been investing in index
funds for a really really long time
index funds index funds index funds and
they've they've made you know they've
made money
and
you know eventually you're going to want
to use some of that money for something
a house down payment or whatever
you
because of the taxes on the gains you've
made are going to have a taxable event
when you start selling those index funds
so you might say well i want 50 grand
for a down payment on my house well
you're going to have to sell more than
50 grand worth to cover the taxes
there are
mechanisms
including tax loss harvesting
and
some other things that you can do like
for like transactions where it might
actually make sense to involve a
financial advisor if the cost is
reasonable in order to deal with that
taxable event okay but that's a really
specific situation the principles at
play here are actually quite simple and
it's just a matter of knowing them and
there are really simple books check out
mr money mustache as a blogger i know a
lot of the stuff he writes is
controversial but what i mean is go back
to the early
his first 50 posts where he lays out a
lot of this stuff
um
how much does a reasonable fee only
advisor cost uh 250 bucks an hour i mean
listen if you're prepared you shouldn't
need more than two hours worth really
genuinely genuinely come develop your
questions ahead of time send them ahead
of time
buy two hours worth of time
um
and you can get most of your questions
answered okay let's move away from this
i think some people aren't liking this
but this stuff i just i really
this guy is so predatory
in the sense that really he's a
right-wing ideologue
who
puts a facade of financial advice on top
of it
that's really what it is
and uh it's it's bad it's bad all right
how did stocks end okay not great okay
so we're standing by for joe biden we're
gonna hear from a momentarily let me say
thank you to a few more people thanks to
ryoshi sama dying in chat
and alpha buds
for the three twitch prime subscriptions
really appreciate that if you're just
joining us after joe biden is done we
also have a
an instagram ama going right now on the
david pakman show instagram
and um let me see how many questions
i've received so far
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20.
wow it's a crazy amount of questions
looks like about
60. i'm as soon as joe biden's done
i will start answering your questions
uh to find this you go to the david
pakman show
instagram
and then click on the logo to get the
stories
and we've got some other stuff on our
top five stories of the week we got a
lot of great instagram content let's see
actually what were the top five stories
of the week let's see
okay mike pillow not allowed into canada
that's a good story
mike pillow says the election's about to
be decertified okay not ben
mike pillow canceled by his own bank it
has been a bad week for mike pillow has
it not
trump admits his financial statements
are inaccurate
trump fraud lawyer admits maybe none of
it is true a lot of lying a lot a lot of
lying this week that we uh that we
covered for sure okay but in any case
this is the post where you can ask me
anything and we will we will get to the
stuff
very very strongly after a joe biden is
done okay other super chats no i have no
super chats
did i miss some they go away very
quickly hold on here's one
what do you think of seven habits yeah i
would read it so um seven habits of
highly effective people by stephen covey
not covet but covey
um some people feel that covey being a
mormon kind of infects the book like a
virus i didn't really feel that i think
it's a useful useful uh book to read
mature adult time says sir are you going
to cover the clearing out of canadian
truckers
uh yeah maybe maybe we'll see i'm kind
of i'm kind of done uh after this i'm
done for the weekend and then we'll see
what's newsworthy on monday david there
was a new explosion in ukraine russia is
claiming ukraine did it to themselves
all right well let's let's see what joe
biden says here momentarily thank you to
beans and weens off green effects
and kratos aureon
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 40.
huge dumps of memberships over on the
website kelly walker signing up with the
coupon code obama obama
melanie gonzalez signing up with a
coupon code obama obama and dustin
kester
signing up with the coupon code obama
obama that puts us at 43
and i invite you to listen folks if
you've been putting it off
it's sort of like life insurance if
you've been putting it off it's good to
just buckle down
and uh
get it done
grab a membership at joinpackman.com
tristan says should i worry about my
trip to sweden in april being cancelled
i don't no i don't think so i don't know
why you mean because of the russia
ukraine thing i would i would doubt it
i think your trip in april is gonna be
fine
um
okay
very good very very good yeah let's
let's actually i am curious because um
biden is running so late let's see what
the latest news are
us officials warn of imminent russian
invasion of ukraine with tanks fighter
jets and cyber
car bomb putin finally springs his false
flag
pretext to invade
190 000 troops holding at the border
zelensky trip to munich raises alarms
russia to stage massive nuke drills
um i i have no idea what joe biden is
about to announce i genuinely don't know
um
this is
there are some saying this speech here
is the last chance
before i guess what there's i guess what
some people are speculating is if this
speech does not signal military action
if there's another speech it's probably
because there's military option actually
okay that's very speculative
david what's your advice for someone
trying to unionize a walgreens i am i
don't know anything you there are union
activists who really could advise you on
that uh i i don't you know people ask me
financial uh personal finance questions
i will answer on uni union activism you
gotta find an expert there
thanks to justin andrew watson for the
twitch prime subscription your number
44.
um okay a couple people wanted a few
more voicemails
all right i'm willing to do a couple
more let's see the voicemail line has
been crazy there's 911 voicemails right
now
that i could play for you let's see
but i think what made the holocaust um
actually like be able to happen and how
it won't be able to happen again
is the amount of power that they've had
they did have on their side when it came
to
you know detaining individuals that they
didn't like you know and it was like
a blonde and a redhead and a brunette in
a room
i've never heard that historical
analysis before
uh
i'm gonna have to look into that yeah mr
peckman i'm looking through your videos
and again i see
you have not done a video on the
attempted assassination of
uh louisville jewish mayor candidate uh
pink greenberg
um by this radical black supremacist
i did not hear about that troy
but i will gladly look into it
i will gladly look into that
uh let's see what else we've got here
so after reading through
uh the
myers-briggs types and the antiograms
and stuff like that man whitney is just
she's been obsessed with myers-briggs
for months i'm just off myers-briggs i
don't i don't find it super interesting
uh mr pacman jamie raskin's father
was a communist and jamie raskin
is a seditionist
corrupt [ __ ] himself actually i i find
jamie raskin to be one of the most
brilliant members of congress
uh i i think jamie raskin is great jamie
raskin is endorsed by the bernie
affiliated
uh pack out is it our future i forget
the name of it
um
i think jamie raskin is uh brilliant
yeah
so we just disagree
but you know the great thing troy is you
can make a show yourself
and you can give your opinion
of jamie raskin
average voter says david sir any tips
for an aspiring speech writer not not
really i don't know much about the
speech writing world i don't know how
one breaks into it so to speak
i'm not sure
thanks to vacant hand for signing up
with twitch prime number 45 today very
much appreciate that
uh let's do it yeah we'll i'll give away
a free item we're at 45
whoever is number 50
gets a free item from my online store
gear be it a t-shirt
be it a hoodie be it a coffee mug or a
hat whatever you want number 50 to sign
up on my website
gets a
free item
a free item
very very powerful offer i can assure
you
uh let's see what else we've got here
i don't know who these people are on the
left who would disagree with you
and
accuse you of being a hegemonic
capitalist imperialist pig
but i'm one of those people on the left
who would not
describe you or characterize you in that
way i wonder why this guy's phone sounds
like this this guy's been calling for
months and there are so many strange
noises on the line all the time
but i do
take the sides take sides with putin in
russia there you go
i think he's a horrible leader
he believes in assassinating his
political opponents like donald trump
does wait so why would you take putin's
side
technically
he or russia is correct
with regards to
ukraine ukraine may or may not want to
be a part of russia that's something for
them to make clear to putin
how does that justify massing 190 000
troops could have maybe maybe there
could be a phone call of some kind i
don't know
um
wow jordan klepper has a video of him
interviewing people at the canadian
trucker rally where can i find that is
that on twitter
that sounds interesting
let's see if it's on his twitter
um
no there's nothing on his twitter for
weeks
anybody know where i get youtube okay
hold on
jordan clepper youtube
jordan klepper on the canadian truckers
ah here we go let's take a look at that
as we wait for joe biden to tell us if
there's gonna be a war
[Music]
three weeks ago north of the border a
new kind of protest emerged the trucker
convoy has arrived in ottawa this city
in the downtown core remains gridlocked
some residents here say that they really
can take
no more so i traveled to ottawa
expecting to find some canada nice but
their messaging was a bit more coarse
these trucks shut down businesses and
made roads impassable can i go
if i go around here how do i
how do i get around but how long were
the protesters planning to paralyze
canada's eighth best city david how long
you been here i've been here since day
one holding down the fort pretty much
i'm not going anywhere i'm coming in
from new york i go by brooklyn's kindest
on the seabee here you go we were able
to stay here up to two years
you're committed to be don't they have
to go to work to some degree i mean i
don't know being here for two years yeah
because two years is nothing are you
going to keep up the energy to be here
for two problems
stimulants no the people bring it i
smoke a lot of weed yeah okay right yeah
but that's just to calm me down and keep
me keep me centered are you worthy at
all with weed paranoia that might creep
in no no no okay
do you think the government is coming
for you
oh yeah constantly they they're they do
like night night uh little tactics they
try to look
they move around they move in they add
more are you paranoid no
sure what kind of stuff do you haul i
haul everything in 2020 i hauled from
food to building supplies
to medical supplies you have my end
table that i ordered from wayfair like
three weeks ago it's probably sitting
either in montreal or toronto or on the
border it would really look great in my
apartment so what exactly was the point
of interrupting the supply chain so what
is this all about you know what sorry
what is this all
a boot
this is about our freedom can you be
any more generic you know if you are
vaccinated you get to do certain things
if you're not vaccinated you don't i
don't think people should be divided we
should all be together united we're
setting up essentially a truck barrier
to keep everybody together so they can
be united yes
gotcha yeah we might as well lock them
in sort of like a parent who locks the
door and says you guys are in here until
the water runs out you become friends or
democracy crumbs yes and if you're not
vaccinated you're literally a
second-class citizen in this country i
can't go to the restaurant i can't go
play hockey i can't go watch the otto
with senators we don't live in germany
we don't live in nazi germany
those days are over just show me your
papers don't happen anymore that's a
freedom that everyone should have is the
germany comparison a stretch here in
canada no are you afraid of cultural
appropriation
probably
american culture i like that he's
probably afraid of it he needs to know
more as to whether it's convenient to
his narrative before telling you whether
he's for or against cultural
appropriation but he will eventually
tell you oops creation because we use
the german excuse all the time oddly
enough that wasn't the only thing
canadians were appropriating yeah i hate
to use that slogan
but uh
make north america great again to meet
north america great again and i don't
mean to use that guy's word but it's
true to be honest it wasn't even his he
stole it from another guy before him i
see the uh the q army on your head is is
it
cube the american thing trying to find
jfk junior exactly yes exactly what q
[ __ ] is going down here huge no q is a
usa oh so this is like a yankees hat ah
exactly
okay the q thing might just be a fashion
choice but they're definitely reading
the same internet as many americans and
it's more than just
my team's past
what else yeah 10 to 20 30 is a good
start
what's agenda 2030. that's where the
world's head towards one government they
want to sterilize us that only certain
people can have kids oh boy oh my god
it's gotten very very very bad there huh
very bad really
you're afraid the government will
sterilize you
probably not me but
not someone else someone else not this
guy
yeah but in two weeks of the cow of a
truck pissing in a mountain dew can
can't be too good for the sperm
production probably stare at already so
what's the difference
so margaret atwood audiobooks are
apparently a thing with canadian
truckers and while shutting down a city
seems to have many obvious downsides hey
excuse me hey
hi
yeah have you seen a prius around here
some see an opportunity coming from
liberal gridlock the truckers are
bringing in customers they're bringing
in tourists from montreal from all
across canada everybody wants to check
this out this is essentially a tourist
boom for ottawa right now you could feel
the tourism in the air right you could
smell it it smells like amphetamines and
uh thrifter blood definitely the flood
of 18-wheeler driving tourists and their
canadian af outfits created legitimate
tension with residents of the city
get a job
no one wants you here the downtown was
shut and there was palpable anger
directed at local media tv
[Music]
we've been walking around here uh there
seems to be a real distrust of media
here oh for sure it's a lot of cameras
up in your face cameras on cameras
and while canadian authorities have
finally enacted emergency measures to
try to clear the convoy so far the
trucks are still there and a well-funded
never-ending street party infused with
misinformation and nationalism feels
remarkably possible in our own land of
the free
where does this movement go from here i
believe it's going to be worldwide i can
only imagine if they really do come to
the united states
it will be way more chaotic than it was
in canada just just from our from the
history of how things tend to go here
that's my sense
um
do our do we know when like is the is
the convoy coming to the united states
do we know at this point i'm not even
really sure
it's gonna come to america yes
definitely do you think this is
inspiring the [ __ ] in america part
of me this is inspiring the [ __ ] in
america it's inspiring people
people of america to join together
to stand for freedom okay if they do
come to america then maybe i'll finally
get my [ __ ] end table
yeah that's that's pretty good i like
that
um
yeah i mean i don't i don't know it's
i think here if they try to block
highways it will be dealt with
differently
is some to some degree it's my sense
laura says cops have arrested at least
70 people from the convoy today truckers
overheard saying put the children in
front of trucks going on right now wow
what a mess what a mess
thank you to daniel schmidt
as well as clifford dunn both daniel and
clifford just signed up on my website
with the coupon code obama obama also
want to say thank you to wow someone
named eat the living and jessica
who signed up via twitch prime guys
that's 49. i promised a free clothing
item from the online store to number 50.
this is the time to get that membership
at joinedpakman.com whoever's next
gets a free item we'll send it anywhere
in the world that has mail service i
don't think
i don't know if i could get a package to
north korea
but i would do what i can to get it to
you
um okay standing by for joe biden sir i
can't find my wife do you know where she
might be yeah i actually don't my audio
box is all messed up here let me see if
i can find the right thing
uh
sir your wife is up in the air there we
go
oh man yeah i've gotta i gotta do
something to to get this all cleaned up
uncharged piccolos oh that that was
errant i i apologize for that
uh
no you
joe biden's an hour late i'm aware of it
guys i'm aware of it we don't really
know what's going on
um let me take a look at my twitter i
mean
the expectation was this was going to
kind of be the last like
you know opportunity to avoid war if
that's the direction things are going
and i'm trying to see if anybody has
tweeted an update as to why this is so
delayed
nothing
i mean i'm guessing something crazy is
going on
uh ian vausch tweeted with regard to
ukraine hope for the best but prepare
for the worst
okay and
i probably agree with them
um
yeah no there's no real news as to why
this is delayed by an hour but it's
definitely strange it's definitely
strange
see if jensaki has tweeted anything
no not really
okay well we don't know if anybody knows
anything you can let me know david
you're smart financially and so clear
you should do financial advice videos
every once in a while yeah producer pat
actually wants us to start a personal
finance channel
it's just a lot of work to do another
channel
but producer pat feels very strongly
that it would be it would be good
uh did i get the time right yes uh oh
here it is here's joe biden
good afternoon this is a major moment
today
i made two vital calls
as i've been making for some
months now
two vital calls
that uh on the situation in russia and
ukraine
the first was to a bipartisan group of
members of congress who are currently
representing the united states
along with vice president harris at the
munich
security conference
the second was the latest in a series of
calls over the past many months
with the heads of state of our nato
allies and our the european union
to bring them up to date on what the
united states thinks is the current
state of affairs please and what's
likely to happen in ukraine in the
coming days
to ensure that we continue to remain in
lockstep
that is the european union and nato
despite russia's efforts to divide us at
home and abroad i can affirm
that has not happened
the overwhelming message of both both
calls was one of unity determination and
resolve
i shared with all of those on the calls
what we know about a rapidly escalating
crisis in ukraine
over the last few days we've seen
reports of a major uptick in violations
of the cease fire
by russian-backed fighters attempting to
provoke ukraine true and the donbas
for example
a shelling of ukrainian kindergarten
yesterday which russia has falsely
asserted was carried out by ukraine
we also continue to see more and more
disinformation being pushed out by to
the russian public
including russian-backed separatists
claiming that ukraine is planning to
launch a massive offensive attack in the
donbass
well look there is simply no evidence in
these assertions and a devise defies
basic logic that's good to believe the
ukrainians would choose this moment with
well over a hundred and fifty thousand
troops arrayed on its borders to
escalate a year-long conflict
russia state media also continues to
make phony allegations of a genocide
taking place
in the donbas
up and push fabricated claims warning
about ukraine's attack on russia without
any evidence that's just what i'm sure
ukraine is thinking of doing attacking
russia
all these are consistent with the
playbook the russians have used before
to set up a false justification to act
against ukraine
this is also in line with the pretext
scenarios that the united states and our
allies and partners have been warning
about for weeks throughout these tense
moments the ukrainian forces have shown
great judgment and i might add restraint
they refuse to allow
the russians to bait them into war
but the fact remains russian troops
currently have ukraine surrounded from
belarus along the russian border
and with ukraine to the black sea in the
south and all of its border
you know look
we have reason to believe the russian
forces are planning to and intend to
attack ukraine
in the coming week
in the coming days
we believe that they will target
ukraine's capital kiev oh god a city of
2.8 million innocent people uh oh we're
calling out russia's plans loudly and
repeatedly not because we want a
conflict but because we're doing
everything in our power to remove any
reason that russia may give to justify
invading ukraine and prevent them from
moving this is not looking make no
mistake
if russia pursues his plans it will be
responsible for a
catastrophic and needless war of choice
the united states and our allies are
prepared to defend every inch of nato
territory stocks are going to dump on
monday collective security as well
we also will not send troops in to fight
in ukraine but we will continue to
support the ukrainian people
this past year the united states
provided a record amount of security
assistance in ukraine to bolster its
defensive so 650 million dollars from
jeff oh monday is a stock holiday good
point fair tuesday stocks are going to
dump let's hope the war is over by
tuesday guys dollars in ukraine and
humanitarian aid and economic support
for ukraine
and earlier this week
we also announced an additional
sovereign loan guarantee of up to one
billion dollars to strengthen ukraine's
economic resilience
but the bottom line is this
the united states and our allies and
partners will support the ukrainian
people
we will hold russia accountable for its
actions
the west is united and resolved we're
ready to impose severe sanctions on
russia if it further invades ukraine but
i say again
russia can still choose diplomacy
it is not too late to de-escalate and
return to the negotiating table
last night
russia agreed that secretary of state
blinken
and foreign minister lavrov
should meet on
on february 24th
february 24th in europe
but if russia takes military action
before that date we'll be clear that
they have slammed the door shut on
diplomacy
they will haven't they will have chosen
a war
and they will pay a steep price for
doing so
not only from the sanctions that we and
our allies will impose on russia
but the more outraged the rest of the
world will
visit upon them
you know
for many issues to divide our nation and
our world
but standing up to russian aggression is
not one of them
the american people are united
europe is united a transatlantic
community's united our political parties
in this country are united the entire
free world is united russia has a choice
between war and all the suffering it
will bring or diplomacy
that will make a future safer for
everyone
now i'm happy to take a few questions
nancy from bloomberg uh thank you so
much sir do you think that it is wise
for president zielinski to leave ukraine
if an invasion is as imminent as the us
says it is
that's a judgment for him to make and
the determination as to whether or not
i've spoken with zielinski
a dozen times
maybe more i don't know
and uh
and uh it's a in in the pursuit of a
diplomatic solution uh it may not be
fault
maybe the wise choice
but it's his decision
and do you have any indication about
whether president putin has made a
decision on whether to invade do you
feel confident that he that he hasn't
made that decision already
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that
wow seems to be a unanimous speech he's
saying there will be an invasion it
sounds like
a comprehensive section but are is
everyone on board with the exact same
sanctions that you want to do
uh
yes um
there will be some slight differences
but none there'll be more add-ons than
subtractions oh
president putin is going to oversee some
nuclear drills this weekend how do you
see that happening what what's your
reaction to that sir thank you
um
i don't think he is remotely
contemplating nuclear
he's using nuclear weapons
but i do think it's uh
i think he is um
focused on
trying to
convince the world that he has
the ability to change the dynamics uh in
europe
in a way that he cannot um but i i don't
uh
how much of it is a
cover for just saying we're just doing
exercises
and and there's more than that i just
can't it's hard to read his mind
i'll take him you are convinced that
president putin is going to invade
ukraine is that what you just said a few
months yes you do oh my god
is diplomacy off the table then no
because all until he does diplomacy is
always a possibility
what reason do you have to believe he's
considering that option at all
we have a significant intelligence
capability thank you very much
oh man
um
president joe biden saying he
now believes
vladimir putin has made the decision
to invade ukraine
over the next few days
um
[Music]
wow
wow uh
i mean this is jarring but i know
someone's waiting for a free t-shirt
connor rowe is the 50th member today so
connor you can you can write in to info
davidpakman.com seems so quaint and
irrelevant given what's going on here
uh but conor and appreciate everybody
else
um okay
so that's quite a segue it sounds like
there's going to be a war
and joe biden says the u.s will not send
troops the u.s will not send troops but
will support ukraine
okay
uh and
someone won a free hat
those are the two messages i guess uh
this is not good
this is not good i don't have too much
else to say
let's hope
let's hope
that diplomacy can still function
um we are doing
and i am doing an ama on the david
pakman show instagram so i'm going to
end the stream because i've got to go
answer questions over there okay so if
you have questions about this or
anything else
find me
asking a question
at david pakman show
thank you